[Music]
before i became an adult and was
conscientious about the world changing
and wanting to make a good
impact on it by eating less meat
i used to love cheeseburgers i ate a lot
of cheeseburgers do you like that
breakfast well i love how much you talk
about wanting to eat less meat i've been
eating instead of just doing it i know i
know i just i think it's a good thing
it's one of your favorite things to talk
about i know and not do i know i've been
trying to do it uh beyond burgers or
delicious impossible burgers i really
enjoy but anyway this was a time when i
ate burger burgers
which is a gross word burger isn't it
kind of a gross word i don't think it's
as gross as cheeseburger yeah
cheeseburger anyway my favorite was from
a place called raleigh's drive-in it
wasn't a drive-in which is confusing but
uh i think it was at one point in time
it's a great and it's still there in
fairfield connecticut it's a great
little cheeseburger
shack it's out shout out um i had so
many moments of just
a sheer delight there sheer delight as a
child eating those burgers i once in
fact ate eight and a half of them eight
and a half burgers in one sitting
granted they were pretty they were thin
uh and that was a time where you could
just put anything into your body i miss
those days i know me too anyway uh but
you know what was unfortunate about
those days what we didn't have a podcast
back then and now we do and it's so fun
here it is i love the optimistic side of
you oh yeah it's really nice well i get
very i'm very excited before i start
these because i like doing them so um i
hope you like listening to them because
you're about to unless you turn it off
right now right now now please don't
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short
hopefully i'm your uh host almost like
yes
life
[Music]
you know why because you've been a guest
on so many things oh yeah maybe yeah
definitely whoa i have like guest
arrogance
like uh i i should be being interviewed
yes you've been a guest as if you as
have i we've been promoting our movie
that everyone's sick of hearing about
lady of the man yeah we've been making
more people sick of hearing about it
that's right um september 17th well it's
out now oh yeah it's out you know today
uh
this is not what we should be talking
about but today it is now out
on blu-ray and dvd oh yeah so go get one
of those well i'm glad i said i'm glad i
slipped up people still watch i still
love those watching old because i'm old
i'm old fashioned but um back to the
burgers though also before we get to the
burgers a lot of fun stuff on the dvd a
lot of um so even if you're not a big
dvd person a lot of out if you like
extras extras yeah it's chock full eggs
bloopers justin and i doing the um the
commentary oh yeah that was fun terry
that was really fun um anyway but yeah
back to burgers we love burgers uh what
was your fav what is your favorite
burger let's talk about that because
people i think people might want to hear
that you mean from at least four people
what establishment yeah i used to love
raleigh's uh you both have to live
rolling it's different uh chico bielek
who was the owner yes is no longer the
owner and um it's not quite the same as
it used to be changed a little bit has
changed but as a kid that was definitely
my favorite eight is a lot that's a lot
my friend doug he once ate three double
cheeseburgers
a hot dog
and a milkshake in one sitting and he
was bigger than you you have i mean you
also are the recipient of an insanely
fast metabolism and yeah to this day
like you eat well generally but there
are times where you
like pull the pin in that grenade and
you are a maniac but you've always been
so thin i it must be your metabolism uh
it must be
yeah i can
and and food just runs through me
sometimes in a way that uh well this
morning on the today show was really
gross actually it was
i had missed my window of you know
evacuation and um
i was on the show without having
imagined having to evacuate and then
not be able to hold your evacuation
while on the today show oh i would be a
nightmare i did imagine that and it was
it was scary to think and that made it
worse it's live it made the pressure
that was building up inside my
body even
more extreme
anyway anywho
um yeah you know what my favorite i
think might be uh shake shack it's great
are you saying in terms of like change
yeah chains i think shake shack might be
my favorite uh okay it's really good
it's really good shake shack is real and
they do a lot of work with no kid hungry
that's great in and out burger's good
too
really i think it's overrated anyway um
well right in with what your favorite
burger is and how you're trying to eat
less meat
uh why are we talking about burgers oh
yeah honey i should ask do you like i
like how you took the reigns yes yeah
maybe the first time yeah no i'm sure
you've done it before um maybe once who
cares i'll tell you why we're talking
about
burgers
burgers
uh is because our guest on the podcast
that we're doing currently
today is the star did you just have to
feel like you had to remind me that we
were doing a puzzle yes yeah our guest
today is the star of the hit animated
show bob's burgers that's bob he's bob
yeah and bob's burgers his name's h john
benjamin and he does a lot of other
great voices he does archer he's archer
he is archer titular
character and um
christian this is uh i think this is how
he got on our radar right is because
everyone kept saying people on social
media
and who would write in except many would
say that you sound like h john benjamin
many people have said that are you
trying to uh raise your voice a little
bit the volume of your voice i don't
think so not consciously
i i knew who he was before that but i
i started thinking about him
much more frequently once people started
comparing my voice to his so uh i you
both have to think of sean benjamin a
lot more after hearing a lot of mentions
of him
yeah me too but now i'm curious oh he
if i really agree because i've only
heard him
as those up until now as these
characters so you know i've also gotten
i've uh an ex-girlfriend used to say
that i sound and i think she's right i
sound like the dog in
family guy oh yeah brian oh yeah bro
what are you doing today just kind of
that that kind of yeah it's seth
macfarlane but it's like a sort of thing
he's doing well he's seth mcfarlane he
kind of doesn't he kind of fancy himself
like a he's like a rat packer like a
dean martin
and he kind of does that that's a very
natural sounding voice for him right as
it is for you but so i've heard that too
but but yeah i'm curious to hear the
real version of h john benjamin because
i've only heard his characters well
you're everyone's about to let's do it
okay uh here it is i was just going to
say one thing about your that brian
impression that you do sounds like my
impression of you
your impression of me is
force your voice down yeah because we
have pretty much the same
i would say
pitch voice right
whenever you do your impression i mean
since like puberty well you've been like
i am christian no it's not that deep
push it down so low because you always
used to be a little bit i'm not crazy
about talking on the phone but you used
to hate talking on the phone i still
kind of do yeah yeah
well when you would so when you'd answer
the phone and this is me because i'd
make you feel more self-conscious
because i would go
my impression of you answering the phone
was hello have we uh
gotten into who cares territory uh i
think we've been there for quite some
time for 130
yeah that could be the name of the show
well here we go uh with another episode
of who cares but luckily people care
about our guests so yeah and they care
about the show we shouldn't say that
because that's isn't that inherently
kind of [ __ ] on the people who
listen no it's not it's [ __ ] out
ourselves okay
but let's not [ __ ] on ourselves i don't
want to get in any [ __ ] on people who
listen okay
if we're [ __ ] on ourselves i want to
like relegate the [ __ ] no we love
listeners we've come full circle in in
this intro [ __ ] wise
can we start the show yeah let's just do
it here he is my introduction to the
legendary voice after after oh boy and
very very funny man h john benjamin
life could be a dream sweetheart
this episode of life is short is brought
to you in part by audible gather the
family for story time magic with audible
listen to imaginative heartwarming and
festive stories original podcasts and
more brought to life by incredible
performers enjoy brand new audible
originals like the cinnamon bear
and exclusives like the christmas pig by
jk rowling fire up modern classics like
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
and so many more all-time favorites
now's the time to listen together go to
audible.com
listen together
that's audible.com
listen together listen now only from
audible
hello
[Music]
you have such such a rich voice you're
probably sick of talking about it i have
a normal voice but i'm a rich man that's
right you have a wealthy voice never
wanted overwhelmed yeah i've i have an
uppercraft voice yes yeah well it's very
classic you have it's a classic sound
it's a dignified sound and yet what a
horrible what an offensive segway and
yet you grew up in worcester mass um
what is it like where are you from is
that an offensive segway just because
you mentioned i just mentioned well no
because i said and yet oh and yeah right
yeah yeah worcester
does have a has an unfortunate
reputation it has this there's a spicy
side to it um
what
right is
what was your upbringing like what what
was your area like that you grew up in
and what is worcester like in general
worcester was like a fairly decent sized
city i i think second to boston oh
massachusetts if those are still the
stats i don't know i haven't checked in
a while i'm not checking population uh
like i used to yeah every day uh i just
don't have time yeah
i grew up in on this sort of this area
called the tetnick area which is like
mixed i would say you know we were like
middle to upper middle class but it
bordered a very sort of tony area of
worcester the west side did you have
accents john i mean you have none if
anything i i i'm curious we're british
had british accents that actually i mean
yeah i grew up in the 70s we were all
just getting over the revolution the
the
1770s
yes right i was like on the front line
in the battle of worcester
my father has the accent my mother's
from new york so oh i think it limited
me i didn't go you know i didn't have
two parents with that doc that talked
like that
i can't even do it but there are times
where it's borders on british like it
could be english the act do you ever
hear that i mean i think that's where it
originated right yeah justin yeah
that's true instrument but specifically
the how it matter how how you use it how
your sound is
um
did you have to write the long the long
a's yeah and all that my my dad does
have like dogs talk a little like this
worcester is slightly different than
boston boston does have the kennedy i
guess they call it the kennedy accent
yeah you know which is uh
but when you get to worcester i think i
don't know like worcester even maine has
like a sort of right like its own
version of maine
always this might be just i might be
making this up but it always strikes me
that it goes up a little bit at the end
there's sort of like this we're going
here and we're going to have something
yeah
right um yeah did people call you john
when you were a kid or was the h
something that you um deliberately
dropped the h name um
the uh jonathan katz the guy i used to
work with said the h stands for half
fectation
um
but it well i did i put it in my name um
uh
for the credits of the first show i ever
did and i don't think it was because
there was another john benjamin i
actually think i think my girlfriend at
the time laura silverman who was also on
the show we were living together and we
did this animated show back in the 90s
oh yeah i love that yeah
yeah she signed my credit name like name
i think as a joke just to make me seem
pretentious oh really
that's and yeah and then i just became
that
i mean i do i have
it does stand for something but you
don't talk about what it is uh hebrew
no um
[Laughter]
my grandfather's name i think it was my
parents who decided i think they my mom
didn't want me to be called harry oh
because he died she didn't want his
death on my hands
um
well
that's a leap she
she killed him oh okay so it was it was
the tree murdered that man uh way to
bury the lead
um no i think they didn't i for some
reason she wanted john and my sister's
name is jody and
it was it was in that era of
people wanting
wanting the same right yes yeah not
matching children um
yeah
70s was 70s was a crazy crazy decade
everybody's name started with the same
letter yeah uh
it'd be funny it was h joe yeah and
there were a lot of that yeah
[Music]
um that's my grandma's name i love the
name jody um
and no offense to you i don't mean that
that's an old-fashioned name but you
don't hear a lot of jokes is it
josephine short for josephine no i like
her name is just like mine just a
nickname
i think i think john well john i guess
is not a nickname like could be
jonathan or for yeah it could be
especially j-o-n yes that you would
think yeah jody i think uh this is short
for
uh
nothing jody that i haven't asked joe
jodethen and jonathan did you guys were
you close growing up you were from the
bible
um
and there's uh
then jonathan begot jonathan
[Laughter]
and kane slade jonathan when you were
growing up did you have a penchant for
for performing were you were you a funny
kid growing up were you like a
gregarious little h john
i was little yeah
that's about it that was very little you
were right i was like a guarded little
kid if i had to qualify yeah i was not
like a performer no i was sort of shy
but i had a magnetism
that way
honestly because i was
very small
i think people like small things
children and adults like small yeah
people i was too john yeah and i was
cute i think yeah
so i did get a sort of uh the attention
that one might get without having to
perform in a weird way yeah no that's
interesting i i think i was kind of shy
but i still had a lot of people always
like wanting to like throw me around
right well my experience was similar and
and i was so little in fact that i
wasn't a threat to anyone so i wasn't
really picked on i was like almost too
easy at target i was just too oh that's
funny
i was definitely picked on but
at the same time like that was you know
there were right levels of attention
yeah i would get some some being punched
in the face all the way to
being you know lifted up and
come here get in my bed yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[ __ ] little guy yeah it's funny to
imagine let's put them up on the top
shelf of the closet yeah yeah hey guys
it's funny doing put me down i can't get
down i can't get down that's what it's
funny to imagine you in that situation
just because you're
because of your voice you have such a
rich and like adult
um
when did your voice develop i mean when
did you start to find that voice oh he's
like the voice i have now yeah
puberty yeah pretty much yeah what's
funny like i started doing
comedy in the
early 90s uh and i my voice has changed
since then and some of the
characterizations i do now like archer
for instance i do like kind of
deliberately lower my voice i i i think
it has lowered over the
time yeah but if i go back and listen to
the first recordings i did as a voice
actor i sound much different yeah i
probably just from getting older yeah
you know balls dropping even
lower
has to go
descended well i'm working on that yeah
yeah
i'm working on that
what is that i do the exercises i'm
joking frequently
what was um
what was the inspiration for the voice
of archer was it was it simply a guy who
was just um
where did it come from was there any
direction it was sort of based on a
previous animated character i did called
coach mcgurk which was i think why they
hired me huh
uh that was in a show called home movies
which this guy lauren bouchard who does
bob's burgers
that was one of his
that was his first show i loved home
movies yeah and that guy was kind of a
blowhard character
and i i do think i made i don't think i
lowered my voice for him but
he was often drunk and so they share
certain dna he was a sort of a depressed
soccer coach but archer
became kind of the more gen genteel
version of that
honestly like i think
archer the voice developed from
me doing these intro spots to my friend
sam cedar's political podcast huh where
i like where i just like pretended i was
a like you know my version of like
the samsito show
like trying to
yeah and then i think that i just sort
of applied that a little bit to
archer i mean i do do different voices
but i'm not particularly good at it but
yeah i was wondering if you do like do
you do impressions um with that voice i
never did no i don't like no i could do
accents and so forth but on the whole
like all the shows the all the animated
shows yeah i've done i've often been
saddled with
used to
uh home movies in particular i
played a few characters but honestly it
was because they wouldn't hire other
actors right i've heard them
yeah we were in like watertown
massachusetts and they were like you
just be a kid like being the kid like
they
they didn't cast but does that do you
enjoy that
john is does that like scratch uh a
niche for you because i know i've been
doing this show efforts for family
whenever that happens whenever they
there's some smaller part and they don't
want to like bring somebody i love i
love
trying out different voices does that
exist oh i i hate that i hate it i'm
like
i'm always like please don't make me oh
really
yes
well lauren bouchard who does bob's
always we have that like
that relationship over the years yeah
i think he might do it on purpose now
well like
he asked you to stretch it as much as
possible but are you from like a theater
background or is that yeah i loved i did
a lot of i started doing plays in high
school um right see i didn't have that
like so i had no foundation ah yeah how
to do like how to like uh
confidently with characters
okay possess a characterization i didn't
like i didn't have that so
i think i was always a little like i
this is going to be terrible i like most
of the roles i started to do but when i
started the first show dr katz i just
played this one role there it wasn't it
was and it was very uh naturalistic
dialogue and it was improvised so you
know that it was really more about being
that one character um which is
not antithetical to voice acting but
it's different you know it's not what
most people commonly think voice actors
are good at doing tons of voices it was
its own like niche
thing it's more like i've never seen
anything like that i mean that style in
animation that that style
right and now you have like that's like
what we're doing is right it's kind of
what we did then
we just sort of like did a live podcast
where we pretended i mean there was
obviously improvisation and
acting but both archer and bob's feel
that way as well is that d is there room
for that on those shows uh bob's because
uh you know when we started doing dr
katz lauren bouchard who runs bob was
the editor
he he edited the show that's how i met
him oh oh oh uh you know yeah that was
he was the only it was jonathan
myself laura who played the actors
then they would bring in comedians to
just record jokes
and then jonathan would uh
after the fact kind of uh add his
uh questions to the comedians
but the main part of the show the part i
was in was you know whatever like this
weird naturalistic sort of sitcom
uh that we just improvised dialogue back
and forth we worked with an outline but
that was basically how we did it oh wow
yeah they would just
uh hand me a one sheet saying like this
episode's about
i want to get you know i want a pet or
something oh that's so funny
and then we just talk yeah and then when
they would the ratio would be like i
don't know uh and lauren would be lauren
was the editor so we would
improvise sometimes for like a half hour
hour and then he would cut that he would
cut that down to like five minutes oh
that's incredible
when did you discover that you were uh
able to do that and when did you
discover that you had an
improv you were good at improv i did the
audition oh
i'd never done anything like that oh
really so your comedy background was
what what more just was it more standard
uh at the time i was doing sketch
and i was in a duo act so i did i wasn't
doing
individual stand-up
but i was doing
mostly sketch and the duo was
essentially a sketch
like based comedy okay and you had
worked with david cross during that time
yeah david cross was the like i guess
the second sketch group i was in one of
the members of
his group poached uh myself and sam
cedar
we were in a different group that
performed in the same venue and and john
glaser was glazer in that group claser
wasn't in that i didn't i didn't meet
clay's until i worked on the jenny
mccarthy show oh for mtv when she had a
show he was on the writing stuff and i
was a writer as well yeah that's what
most of my remaining questions are about
um
is johnny mcmahon
not the show just her yeah personally
just the gossip about her yeah
oh um no no
what was that experience like
it was good i you know i they were
really good right well
myself and my writing partner we were
from boston that was kind of our first
writing job his name was mike lee he was
a stand-up
and we went out together yeah we met
like we met glazer and we met will forte
and oh yeah that's right forte wrote for
that um
so it had and there were some
groundlings uh yeah you were the writer
performers they were you know they were
trying to do saturday live kind of copy
did you have aspiration like when you're
writing for somebody else and you hear
them do your material is there a part of
you that thinks i should be doing this
or like this this would be better in my
voice it's funny we
glazer and i
kind of built our own
little like production
company
within the show to the credit uh or not
of the producers this guy named joel
gallon oh yeah sure yeah mtv's
yeah mtv's he did all the like mtv shows
yeah
he was never happy but he was like uh
with what we were doing but we kind of
like went off and produced our own
sketches
and would shoot them oh wow i don't know
how we got got away with it but i think
we spent a lot of their budget
sketches that didn't involve jenny
mccarthy it was always all glazer and i
really that's amazing
we did like i feel like we've like
we produced this like series called the
paramedics like they were these two
characters who were like the world's
worst paramedics everybody who get would
die in our ambulance
and then and then john ennis from uh
from mr shows uh
he was the uh
whatever the the
our boss who would yell at us like you
know another god damn it you too
99 of the people
and we think we did like four of those
and like we just handed them to and they
aired them oh my god that's really cool
that's really fun so we had this like
little pirate
operation going on there so that was fun
and uh i definitely wrote some sketches
for for her
but
but we were mainly just sort of working
for ourselves sean do you miss that that
type of performing i mean you do so much
voice over work now obviously but um do
you have a desire to do more of that
stuff not so much anymore i don't think
like i
you know i did a sketch show from in
like 2011 maybe i wish we did more of
those um we got canceled after one
season
and since then i've done a lot less you
know
acting and sketch work well now there's
so much i mean you know there's so many
other obviously uh platforms and stuff
and i just started following you on
twitter you're so funny on twitter
you've been doing a lot a lot of bird
videos um
that are so good uh i really funny but
i would encourage everyone to check
those out but what what got you how did
that start how did your interest in
birds come about that's funny i had my
well it wasn't my lifelong dream but i
got interviewed by audubon society cool
well i was interested in birds when i
was a kid and i forgot like it was a
repressed memory
i must have that was probably one of
those moments where
some somebody punched me in the face
from worcester
that's funny i like i love birds like
boom like punch in the face
[ __ ] idiot never say that again
[ __ ] bird nerd
um i think i used to talk about that i
used to draw uh birds and i did i just
like i said i don't i'd lost i i guess i
lost lost interest for
and then in the like at the beginning of
the pandemic i think it was just a
comfort thing i just started uh sort of
doing like
minor
not minor
minor bird watching that's not a pun but
a little bit of bird watching here and
there because we moved upstate new york
yeah for a
long period of time like we were up
there for four or five months and then i
had really kind of nothing to do they
were still producing the animated shows
and they'd set up like i built this
studio in my apartment no i found myself
doing the same thing john um i'm in
connecticut and
that we live in an area with uh my my
brother's fiance got she's she's really
into birds and and she got all these you
know little bird feeders and stuff and
um
i was sort of like
not teasing her at first i thought it
was charming that she did that but i i
certainly it was certainly wasn't
anything that i was all that interested
in and i found myself just
really watching them a lot and enjoying
them so we started writing down which
ones we'd see and i i there's some
goldfinches around here that i started
blowing my mind once you start looking
yes yeah once you pay attention yeah
it's really it's yeah
uh that's the same exact same thing
happened i mean basically though i got
hit hard early
uh because there was a family of eagles
oh my property
so
that's a that's a silly way to put it i
got hit harder yeah
um
you know i got hit hard
yeah big dogs
um i don't know i just was like holy
[ __ ] the eagles
yeah oh my god i don't think i've i mean
i might have seen them from a distance
and they were living on the property wow
nesting there so there's a whole family
and that was really i think probably
what started it oh so cool and i think
that might have been the first video i
made just because i was like literally
excited to live
yeah have eagle neighbors yeah we have
not to uh we have eagle neighbors on i
live in massachusetts where i live in
massachusetts and there's there's an
eagle on
that that everyone gets excited about i
mean like because it flies around and
hunts and it'll get it'll pick just to
see it grab
a fish from the water with its talents
you know there's something so
captivating about
no i love that i love that that vicious
vibe yes
yeah yeah we lit we i lived on a creek
as well so the eagles were nesting right
on the creek and so they would do a lot
of hunting and you can hear them they
have that like kind of like a weird
shrill
yeah uh yeah
yeah
yeah can you do it
i can try hey
hey
um
and then from there i made the
i think just out of my excitement i
started making those videos and that was
just like sort of just to pass the time
you just posted one just a wet people's
appetite for your twitter um about a a
pretentious
a guy an impression of a guy a
pretentious bird watcher who saw a very
specific bird
oh yes i think that was the last one i
did because i did see a
chat but i then what's funny about
posting on twitter is now i have a lot
of birders
who are really serious probably who are
far more knowledgeable than me about it
and they were like you didn't see a chat
no way like impossible that wasn't a
chat bernards true burger it was i
googled it
yeah
they're like sorry
sorry you didn't say that i called
[ __ ]
i love that element of
nerd dumb people who are fanatic like
that any any sort of fanaticism about
something as like kind of innocent and
fun as a bird that's me yes yeah that's
really funny right and i've gotten into
now like sort of
in-depth conversations with you know
actual like ornithologists is it
ornithologist yeah ornithologist yeah or
oncologist uh hornithologist horn
thought that's right right that's the
porn version um h
uh so what what's your favorite do you
have a favorite bird
i don't know uh
i love a good i love a good nut hatch oh
who doesn't but no
when you saw the chat like you made a
funny video but is there also a part of
you that is like genuinely excited to
see something like that
well there was like definitely some
birds that i did like stumble on i think
i made a video that went like that got a
lot of views
about experiencing or seeing uh a
it wasn't a thrasher but it was a really
cool bird to see like you said like you
see a goldfinch and you're just yeah
it's it's a spectacle yeah like a blue
heron he's like whoa that's like pretty
yes so we had we had a great blue heron
on the pond where we stayed too so
there was a great area for birding and
actually
i live right near prospect park and oh
crosstalk park has a ton of birds i saw
a baltimore oriole the other day oh wow
but apparently there was a black bernie
and warbler what does that look like i
don't know if you care i i do
embarrassingly uh looks like blackburn
blackberry who black blackburn oh no
blackburn blackburn i think is the name
of the guy who
first observed
you know
oh he um
i i would see that would excite me at
baltimore i saw red wing black bird the
other day and that was exciting um
yep that's a bit that's a really good
word to see yeah right and then and then
like now when i post stuff and i did do
just by chance i stumble on things that
become
controversial
or discussions for birders to come back
at me because i was talking about why
certain birds are named after
certain ornithologists or naturalists
back in the 19th century and then
they're they're sort of getting like
not me too but like they were bad people
oh oh really oh god so there's all this
like
like in the burning community a
thrust to change names based on like the
black i like so the black bernie and
warbler is named after this guy named
blackburn and whatever he
um i don't know you know like he
he pillaged a community or right or
it was a slave owner or yeah you know
wow i didn't know that so i mean well
now i'm afraid for darwin i mean god
forbid they come after
uh you have to change a lot don't come
out don't come after my darwin yeah
yeah well the uh audubon i think had was
actually had some some
some stuff going on oh john john h john
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry to blow
this up um no i know this is getting
controversial there's a lot of great
sound bites from for buzzfeed uh yeah
19th century scandals i mean even the
audubon society i think has brought up
the fact that audubon's had some
problematic history uh-huh well well the
galapagos who didn't who didn't yeah my
god i mean it was a problematic time
yeah um
yeah
the galapagos is a place that i've
always been so fast since i was a kid
and
the birds there are
yeah it's so incredible so unique not
just the finches but um some of the
right it's an insane variety of shirts
right it's this like right it's like a
magical place yes it's like my kid went
there really yeah two summers ago he
went ecuador with the summer program and
then
and
and they took a trip to galapagos oh
he's he's been and i haven't and then
that doesn't seem fair
yeah and he's going to college and i
think we just recently i like do you
remember galapagos and he was like not
really
i'm like oh my god
oh my god how wait so he's 18
he's 18 yeah oh my god i can't believe
he got to go there was it what was he
studying it was this uh adventure travel
camp that did service work wow so they
flew to ecuador they
somehow
tried to bring
plumbing to a
uh village yeah i can't imagine that
worked out
[Music]
they've apparently been going in the
same village every year with this group
of kids you know like probably half from
new york and like have absolutely no no
knowledge how to set up plumbing and
they've been going to the same village i
was joking to him like you're
they're just tormenting this village the
village is like yeah i'm gonna try this
again you're gonna get yeah every summer
you're gonna get 15 obnoxious kids from
the united states and they're going to
[ __ ] up your plumbing again
oh yeah i can't feel it i can't yeah
you dug another hole still not working
we'll be back next summer i'll try
[Music]
again the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
dear kids are they into your show they
watch your shows bob's burgers and
archer yeah he used to i don't think he
follows either anymore
do you have similar voices does he sound
like you he does have kind of a deep
voice um
but i think he stopped watching both of
them maybe when he was in like fourteen
or fifteen uh-huh and he said well we
used to watch bob's burgers together
when he was young young it's been on so
long now
when it start when it started we he was
we would watch it together but now he
doesn't yeah how often do you get to
record you see i mean obviously now
we're recording everything separately
but um was there a time when you guys
were able to record together it was that
like you and kristen and
the rest yeah that was pretty pretty
pandemic that was the last time we did
that and now they record archers was
recorded separately
since the beginning of the show that we
all
did our parts uh individually so you
never really see each other until you're
doing some sort of promotional thing
yeah exactly yeah i didn't meet the cast
of archer till the year
the the summer after the show came out
oh my god
when we first promoted it right yeah uh
isn't that funny um what's up when i met
them at uh
to
ccas yeah yeah yeah and now it's where i
made poo poo in my car right before
oh youtube it's a long story oh no we
have time that's the nice thing about
podcasts
i mean i've told the story on aisha oh
uh naisha's podcast so i won't tell the
whole thing again okay the short version
is i diarrhea in my shorts and
they validate it
for me
it was like the worst night of my life
and then i met the cast that like we had
like an 8 a.m
and i had had
diarrhea all night
on p on people well not on people
do you know
it was the aftermath of flying first
class i think like maybe for the first
time
and i i might have overdid it just by
what you ate and drank on the plane
did you have like three bottles of wine
and some frozen fillet
that didn't sit well on the drive to
pasadena
so you actually
went it was it on the
upholstery of the seat was it around
well i for some reason all i remember
was i was in i flew in shorts
that was a good idea i think i was like
i was very into
being aggressively annoying back then
and i just remember i think i was on
vacation in massachusetts in gloucester
oh yeah beautiful i remember my agent
calling saying you have to go to this
thing and i was like i'm not going and
he was like wait what i'm saying i'm not
going i'm in i'm on vacation he was like
you have to go you're like
it's the first promotion of archer i'm
like i'm seriously i don't want to go
i'm like i'm here for another three days
and then i don't blame you by the way
but that's a really it was a little bit
i think that was sort of half
that was half joking but i kind of
didn't want to go
and then i was like well you tell them
the the only way for me really to get
from gloucester to
logan airport is a helicopter
and this was the first time i sort of
experienced like
that in show business it doesn't matter
whether you're joking or you're serious
he was like let me get back to you
and i was like wait what let me get back
i'll call them like they might
they might then he called back with the
heliport options oh my god but at that
point you don't want to say i was just
joking because you know it's like whoa i
have uh well i was gonna take the
helicopter but it was like an hour and a
half north of
like the helicopter was longer
further away from the i was like just
that's fine i'll go i'll just get me a
car that's and then that
that story ended with the me getting
probably punished
yes karma gods for doing that
did you so it was so you're in the same
shorts that you flew in i flew in the
shorts and then i drove
uh was it the
405 uh-huh yeah up north yeah and all
the it was so late the plane that all
the they were doing
road repair on all the exits so i
couldn't get off and i didn't really
know it was pre gps oh okay i didn't
have
i didn't have gps so i was like i don't
really know how to get to pasadena oh
and
i was moving up the 405 way north like
past spaghetti museum and all that right
so you must have been panicking
i was just like i don't i i gotta get
off and find my way i think i knew how
to get through
like i took the long way like i knew how
to get through west hollywood john in a
situation like that do you panic because
i'm putting myself there and i would be
i i mean it manifests in like i would be
shaky i'd be it would have all the
physical manifestations of a true panic
but is yours just like you [ __ ] yourself
well
that at the time
it hit me like you know like a wave like
it hit me like immediately
like a and i was like kind of i feel
like i was in like
westwood or something
when it happened and then i was like i
gotta find a bathroom and so
i was doing a lot of
stopping at gas station to gas station
nobody had a bathroom oh my god i was
like i know i'm gonna have to
eventually go on somebody's lawn or
somewhere
yeah i was trying to avoid that i made
it all the way like i made it like 10
minutes to pasadena i was in a full
clench for like a half hour
what an awful feeling then i hit a bump
and it like it just like that's that was
just
it was like unleashed
a beautiful release oh god that's that
must be a strange feeling because it's
like
yes physically technically it must feel
good it's got to feel good yeah and then
the aftermath obviously is like you know
then you're like oh no like
it's just immediate shame well i just
knew i had to like
i don't know i didn't know where to
begin the cleanup process right because
it was that
it was that much i mean it was yeah and
then it was happening again oh and then
so i finally did pull over it's not that
like it was at that um what is it it's
it's like a super fancy hotel where they
had that like at the ritz
or something yes i know what you're
talking about where there's this like
grand entrance that like leads you up uh
god and that was for fx right we might
have been at the same one i was on an fx
animated show called unsupervised at the
time
and i think i went to
i remember going to that tca whatever
you might have you might have smelled me
i'd remember that
jackie earl haley i remember came
like after i figured out after i
sort of got cleaned up but still had to
come clean to the desk clerk because it
was awful oh god they tracked me i ran
as the hotel covered in diarrhea
clean up
and then security
security followed me obviously because a
man
with diarrhea all over him just ran into
their hotel like it was i didn't check
in
so i was absolutely targeted as as an
insane person i think they were gonna
like call local police were you wearing
shorts still the shorts yeah i had the
shorts but
but i so i was trying to clean up in the
bathroom
can you
that was a comedy in itself because i
was like running down the bathroom was
not easy to find in this big grand
lobby and i ran down a hallway and i was
just running around like just running
[Music]
like
rudderless are there people milling
around are there no it was late late
late like it was like two in the morning
at that point oh my god are there soup i
know it may be one in the morning it was
super late because you couldn't check
into the hotel you couldn't you could
stop and be next to somebody i was like
in a like just a i was in an awful state
you know so i was just like i just i
think i made a plan like i'm going to go
and clean up did is the car is it just
all over the car at this point yes it
was all over the car and i made a series
of mistakes along the way and one of
them was to forget my backpack in the
car
so i went in with nothing to change into
so
it was a mess it was like that was also
like
mentally exhausted i bet i bet two in
the morning after a flight what are the
mechanics of that like i've never been
in that situation thank god yet uh when
you're in the bathroom and you don't
have a change what do you do
i
i went into the stall and like
wiped everything down and then
uh i hate to say this but i did put my
shorts in the sink no i you have to i
had to yeah i tried as best i could i
think to not like but then i feel like
i just
i needed to tell
somebody and i finally did and i just
like that that would have been a much
easier process if i was just like please
help me yeah i bet if i just got there
and told the valet like help like oh the
fact you imagine thank you hug him and
say i need help like i need you to help
200
but i didn't do that and so it made it
worse and worse along the way and by the
end i had like now they're right that
bathroom was a disaster
that they the h john bathroom
they called
also they had the uh top the towels and
not paper do you know what i mean like
it was oh yes
so at least it wasn't an air dryer i'm
wetting i'm wet yeah and and the cloth
like
the
um hamper
so it i've even made it worse because
i'm just throwing like [ __ ] covered
tiles into their hamper
but i suppose like in the morning if if
they hadn't discovered me they would
have been like
there was
like some awful parent just cleaned up
their kid and dumped it all in the
right they wouldn't be able to tell that
it was adult diarrhea yes i was going to
throw my shorts out
uh but i forgot my backpack right you
would have walked out that i would yeah
and then at that point i was just like
are you right you're all right i could
have just asked for a robe
yeah i remember i got locked i locked
myself out of my hotel room in toronto
uh naked fully naked
and um
i just had my i had to just face the
door i mean i was like cupping my
genitals and and fortunately a
house a house cleaner person came by
it was like four or five in the morning
no no it was it was earlier it was like
five in the morning i'd gotten
anyway i i got a towel from somebody
thank god and i i was able to go down to
the lobby but i remember going to the
lobby in this towel which is also like
it's just surreal it's like this
because it's um
you know i i didn't i never had that
experience and they're people milling
around it was i remember it being early
enough in the morning that people were
like checking in and there was like a
there was like a bustle of like
morning activity and i was like
kind of still drunk from the night
before i mean it was i was a mess and
kid like families checking in and i had
to get
i had to get extra keys i of course i
had no idea so thank god somebody was
like
i remember the first person was like i'm
sorry who are you you know thank god one
of the people there were like no no i
remember him he's in the room whatever
um did somebody hand you like uh
something to cover you no no because i
had a towel they just gave me my keys oh
okay and i tried i remember trying to be
very like nonchalant i remember like
trying to effect an error of like
casual kind of like oh hey yeah no i
just need my i just locked myself out
you know no big deal um why are you
wearing a towel play it cool yeah i'll
always play cool
who i yeah
um but in in that case like sh that to
me is i'm so fascinated because it's
like it really is like one of those
personal nightmare scenarios that people
you know can you imagine it's like it's
such a like hypothetical can you imagine
if that happened and then when it
actually happens like i'm curious about
the mechanics and like the
just the logistics of the whole thing
like like yeah
it was really fun and it kept escalating
it was a good i mean i still i tell the
story like probably once a year
selling it now and i oh it's great i've
told it before but it's yeah it was a
really crazy version of that because it
kept it kept escalating and then finally
i was taken out by security and brought
to the desk and that's when i just sort
of oh you you asked
yeah finally like uh
the security came into the bathroom
they found me like they were they were
after me
oh was there like a little trail like i
said i was like running around like yeah
so hairy to try and find a bathroom i
like found a bathroom like
up a half set of stairs and it wasn't it
was like by the banquet like i was to
them it must have seemed like i was like
height you know like trying to hide from
them oh yeah in their defense it must
have been a very
sis like suspicious looking
totally straight like a literally an
insane person came in covered in
diarrhea and we've got to arrest him
stan jackie earl haley came to end the
story that was really good because i got
a celebrity cameo into this
how was he he came into the lobby
because he was and he was drunk no i i
have no problem with that
but he was really he came in after like
partying uh or i don't know
what he was doing but he was definitely
drunk
and he i think had like just wanted he'd
lost his key or something like me
yeah like you and then he
blurted out like what the [ __ ] like holy
because it stunk
and uh right because i was like having a
conversation with the desk clerk who was
like you know kind of had her like
handle oh john was covering his face
like we are we'll help you we'll get you
into your room
were you laughing would you apologize at
that point i was sort of like this has
just been so
bizarrely awful and i just i just want
to
please
like
please get me to
like a shower yeah and like a doctor and
just and i if you want like you you can
wash me i'm too tired maybe to even do
that well you have no shame anymore too
i mean yeah i was just like just
stripped me down yeah but put lime on me
just a like prison style host me exactly
yeah hose me
get me to the room with the drain and
so jackie have you seen jackie earl
haley since i don't i don't even think
i'm i didn't meet him that night but i i
knew who he was oh my god i'm dying now
to ask him his perspective of this he's
gotta i hope you know him yeah i
oddly got had some drinks with him once
um okay but i asked him to do the show
and he was like oh yeah he seemed like
into it or he was being polite oh cool
um so
i would i got now i really want to if
you you have that in and see if he
remembers you might not remember how
could i forget like you know
like
that's
got to be indelible i would think so i
guess unless like you know maybe
which adult covered in diarrhea in a
hotel lobby was this well right
let's see i've um
i've seen like i've seen that like i
don't know
10 12 times
but little guy
yeah what sitting
here was either the one and there was
either one in the bar in joshua tree or
joshua tree
what um
so did you tell all the cast because and
also you're meeting the cast for the
first time that's intended yeah i was
meeting the guy and the producers oh so
god the guy who
i don't i don't we all only did it over
the phone like i was doing it in a new
york studio so
and
you should have blamed my helicopter
to bed at like you know like 3 30. oh my
god i had to get up at like 7 30.
i remember i did tell people after i
think i like to get right right to the
panel
how do you begin that story with people
your first meeting
like what's the intro to that story well
i did like know i knew them because i
like yeah yeah over the year i just had
never met anybody but when like aisha
says like hey john oh
like aisha i'd never met like i know i'd
never even talk to talk to because like
i said we recorded separately yeah but
the
matt and adam the creator of the show
uh i've talked to them frequently every
every record but i didn't like i knew
chris parnell a little bit from new york
uh but i was meeting all the actors
really like like jessica and uh
jessica walter and i was meeting them
for the first time that morning like i
had never talked to them oh sad that
they're so do you don't tell jessica
walter that story do you
i think i did
i think we like went and
had breakfast or something and i was
over breakfast
that's not a strange part i had to grab
a bagel
you just you needed starch
yeah i had
emptied everything out
that's a replenish it was all in the car
and maybe i told jessica that um
she would she would like a good story ah
that's cool what a this is what a loss
she was such a good actress um
i love turning this movie the flamingo
kid when
i grew up when i was growing up it was
one of my favorite movies oh yeah yeah
she played um
she uh so what happened after she after
she passed i watched play mystic for me
again and it was really fun it was i
hadn't seen it in so long
she's so good um
what was what was the car like not to
labor this just to dwell on this more
but i uh i just
so curious about the like are you
planning
a to have diarrhea in a car um and
that's why you're asking maybe maybe
subconsciously or if i were this would
help this would help
do not first of all do not have diarrhea
in the car okay that's good first
having told this story don't do it yeah
uh if you can avoid it if you
if you do
have it i wouldn't do it voluntarily if
you do have it valet it
i would never do that i would i would
rather it just get
like a boot on it from the cops i'd just
park it in the middle
i
was a rent-a-car it was a and i'd
it was a rent-a-car from the airport do
you want to shout out the company uh
national oh great national so if you are
were to have diarrhea that's a good you
know endorsement of their company
and i am a diarrhea club member which is
probably why
they
they fixed that that's probably why
because you just push a button and
they'll come
just absolutely steam clean i have
triple a and triple and triple d
um
what what did they what did you do with
because you had to get back in the car
though right at some point well the the
i ended up going out
after i went upstairs
to thinking uh
that i have to deal with the car yeah
because i left the car and then the in
the whatever you call that the circle
they're like yeah the port oh my god
yeah
um oh thank god
it was gone
so they took it oh no so somebody took
no car and cleaned it
no yes and i told like i went like they
cleaned my car i don't know how
but it was pretty much like it wasn't
brand new but they cleaned the seat
that's incredible oh it must be
like a valet did that like whoever took
the car but so there is somebody out
there maybe listening there's somebody
out there who clearly like brought it to
the
parking area and took a towel and
cleaned it all up aren't you dying to
know their story aren't you dying
tonight i do i've always wanted to like
somehow reach out to that person because
they like i can't believe they did that
okay look i i'm gonna six we we get
letters on the show if you are that
person if you happen to be listening to
this please write into life is short at
wondery.com
life is short at wondering.com if you
are the valley or or know the valet or
can track them down
uh we got to get them on we got and i i
we should offer them something like uh
you know
you should well in all expense paid yeah
i would we
um
well if you'll help out i will i will
it's worth it it would be nice to kick
in
it's worth it maybe national we can
sponsor national uh we can get them to
sponsor it just to tie up right to tie
up loose ends
so to speak yeah
yeah
i will fly that person to
to uh to new york okay to to
and to clean me up again oh that doesn't
seem like uh
but but uh a flight to new york would be
nice
yeah i mean i would like to new york
would be nice and then yes so john is
promising a round-trip flight to that
person round-trip flight economy new
york
business
um sleeper car okay okay um
uh wow amazing thank you for that john
um speaking of the new
season premieres um archer premiered on
fxx on august 25th we're going to talk
more about it with my brother uh we did
the outro the intro and outro together
and
we
we often get letters that say um or he
gets comments on
instagram and stuff where
many people say he sound like he sounds
like you
he often okay so i'll i'll hear him at
some point yes and i'm curious then what
um yeah curious what you think if he
does do i get to hear the outro or you
do that separately uh we'll do it
separately but um
you'll you'll hear it when it's all done
oh when it's done right so i won't hear
him now no i'll just go ahead i wonder
if he's around wait hold on one second
this is breaking protocol but i'm
curious
hey correct correct
no
you live with your brother what's that
you live with your brother i do i do
yeah he's not here we live near our
parents too 43 years old um
he's not here at the moment but uh both
live with your parents no no we live
nearby we live about five minutes from
the parents he's at the parents house
now watching uh our nephews our little
our older brother has two kids oh okay
yeah that's so that's cool yeah
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge-watching
low-budget made-for-tv holiday movies
the all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wandery plus in the wondery app
hello hello
[Music]
we just have a quick
lightning round we asked the same
questions to everyone i feel intelligent
is going on um
what is your most commonly used emoji
if you use uh
[ __ ] um
[ __ ] no i don't use the [ __ ] one um
thumbs up yeah
and that's not because i'm a positive
person
right what's is it sorry it's sarcastic
usually like a cert down
yeah i think it's just i don't want to
write anything i don't want to like
write words
can't wait to do that podcast when i do
so if you get a thumbs up from me um i
i'm most likely lying
okay that's good to know
um that's good for your friends to know
or your enemies
um if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play the
baseball yeah okay do you have a team
baseball favorite team red sox
from my childhood but i i mean the
baseball just seems like the best
lifestyle wait i know doesn't it yeah i
know especially like especially for like
relief pitchers i i always think of that
guy bartolo cologne
yeah it was just like this
he just seemed like he enjoyed life he
was a big guy
he'd come in every couple well there was
a day when you didn't have to be in
shape for pretty much any sport that's
true that's true um right i feel like
you go back like yeah
well fisk was probably in decent shape
but of course like yeah you smoke and
drink and i guess you could do that in
every sport now as well but
conditioning certainly has changed and i
would veer towards
i i know i could have picked like uh i
don't know uh bobsled yeah no that
wouldn't matter but or like golf or
something
right there's a great but even golfers
now are like kind of insane i know
yeah i know there was a meme going
around some really it was really funny
when uh tom brady
beat the record for it was a longevity
record for like i think is the oldest
the oldest person to play
either quarterback or in the super bowl
or something like that he beat george
blanda's record no no it has to be in
the super bowl or in a playoff game
because i think blanda played till he
was 48 but
and they were both i don't know 43 44
but they had a side by side of them at
that age and of course tom brady looks
like you know
yeah he's just like resplendent and um
and george black he's a beautiful man i
saw him in a lobby of a hotel once again
not that lobby
no i saw tom brady and i immediately
release my bowels
like that's what i do when i see a
beautiful man
oh
god
oh
mr brady
can i please have you oh oh autograph
jackie you're all haley comes by not
again like the perfect jackie or haley
cameo again yeah
you always enter is drunk
oh
[ __ ]
i can't go to a hotel
[Laughter]
that would be the oldest that's jackie
earl haley for airbnb i'm trying to
think i can't go to a hotel
it's smelling [ __ ]
this has been jackie or haley for airbnb
i'm trying to think of the person who i
would be most ashamed
to diarrhea in my pants in front of
and tom brady's got to be up there
he seems pretty like affable affable but
also like
really impressive and clean and like
physics like probably shit's like
perfect like the compact you know
right with that with that tb12 diet is
like right his shits are like these
little pellets
he can like re-ingest his shits they're
so like kind of perfectly pretty
confused food yeah it's actually like
he's a totally like self he's a
self-sustaining system yeah oh [ __ ] i
haven't eaten breakfast i just have a
brady bar
and it's just like oh like hey it's like
um
speaking of brady bars what is your
go-to snack food what is your like
favorite if you could have one snack
food for the rest of your life
chips
specific brand you want to shout out
maybe they'll send you product
lately
what am i uh it's a i think k-e-o-g-h
it's either irish crisps hugo keys
i have no uh how to pronounce if a
representative for a representative for
kyo who is
listening
right
uh but i also might be wrong but it's
close to that okay that's what i've been
eating that's what i've been eating
lately very good sour cream and onion
and
really good plain salt and pepper that's
a good lesson too if you're going to
start a potato chip company i mean of
course you want to concentrate on making
delicious potato chips but also like
it'd be nice to have to name your
company something that is like very
clear and
easy to
say
like
right oh i see it right but i it's only
because of my failing memory oh okay
i'm not picturing the label okay so we
shouldn't blame kia don't blame don't
blame him
okay
uh what what's a movie john that you
were really excited when you had kids um
that you were really excited to
introduce your kids too that that was
like a an important movie to you maybe
growing up oh um
2001 oh really yeah what was the reason
it was actually it was the first movie i
ever it didn't work out for me or my kid
but that was i remember being traumatic
from when i was a kid my parents took me
to see that in the theater when it came
out oh my god yeah and i remember like i
still remember the feeling of being
insanely afraid of the beginning yeah i
bet yeah turned down like existential
dread i mean it's a really dark right
and then they like literally like a 30
minute like psychedelic uh
like no dialogue yes your parents
probably thought it's a space movie yeah
yeah it would be like yeah
like star wars yeah
yeah it'll be fun i but that did not
show i think i was most excited to show
my kid uh miyazaki movies oh yeah i did
not watch those as a child i just knew
that yeah yeah
yeah experience so like totoro and
spirit
stuff like that and he did really like
those so that was i yeah that's good
because that's such a concern of mine
john like because i'd love to have kids
and i sometimes think like wow these
movies that were precious to me or
things that if i were to show them to my
potential hypothetical child and they
and they didn't like them or they were
bored or they thought you know
that'd be tough i think for me
to handle oh right yeah you have to sort
of give up um yeah i just sort of
learned that with my kid like yeah i
i've i did try to like sort of force
movies on him for a while and he was
just like please don't show me
i don't want to watch serpaco
yeah i not cruising again
um
but um
it's really good right
right
what's your go-to karaoke song if you
were to sing karaoke
i haven't sung karaoke in so long
times
i would neil diamond yeah i guess
because yeah right
he's in my wheelhouse totally yeah shy
who who was your very first celebrity
crush
probably
richard burton no um
i think i certainly had a fair faucet
poster
i had that i had that iconic one yeah um
with the bathing suit in the side yeah
anytime you see a movie of that from
that about that era about that i feel
like it's always in the art department
always puts one of those posters up yeah
that was really nice
yeah
oh really yeah yeah if you could just go
to spencer gifts and i would that that
was my
right like so any
maybe adrian barbeau yeah
possible and i definitely had a crush on
cheryl t
comes up a lot she was a model yes yeah
right yes it was you're aware of
yeah these are like old-timers
way back yeah you're not going away oh
you are
because you're probably younger than me
so those were like yeah i was like early
teen i was just talking to
some uh fred savage who was um
i think my age maybe a year older but um
yeah we had the same point of reference
for he he specifically said sports
illustrated models of that era and i had
said we were talking about [ __ ]
but but a little bit earlier like ours
was more like kathy ireland um
you know claudia schiffer that that era
i think right yeah yes those are like
the supermodels right when they open the
bar yeah we probably shouldn't talk
about this for too long um we should go
to that we should go i wish i wish we
could go to that bar
wasn't that like in rocky yeah it was
this
model that's right that couldn't have
lasted for more than i mean can you
imagine that today
good lord
um
if if you had to get a tattoo john what
would you get
uh
a tea bag on your scrotum
it'd have to be on your scrotum
i mean uh
i guess i could make the whole thing
yeah
yeah sponsored by lipton
right
then the the label right down my thigh
string
string in the
okay
i should have guessed that
uh what is your favorite fruit
jesus these are really easy
yeah
these are so easy and i'm having a hard
time with all of them
apple apple
apple um is a specific type of apple
h apple pie um
i do like sour um ten towards transfer
so probably granny smith okay but i
would like a good i like a good
gala things like that upstairs yeah goes
um
yeah
um yeah i can't wait for apple's season
i think you're our first granny smith um
who would you like to play you in your
biopic
um
your brother um uh
no he sounds like me
all right christian who is your favorite
muppet growing up
of oscar
oscar okay yeah were you into sam the
eagle a friend of ours was curious oh
um no yeah i was actually afraid of sam
the eagle i used to leave the room um
what is your go-to pizza topping john
sausage pepper onion probably and do you
prefer the and is there a place that you
really love you lived in new york for a
long time for a slice i usually would go
to joe's because i used to eat i used to
live in the west village
so
that would be my go-to place
over um do you ever go to bleaker street
pizza i like bleaker street too but i
would definitely go to me too
preferred shows um do you for dogs or
cats i'm allergic to both so
but
i i think i'm less allergic to dogs so i
thought
if i had to be relatively sick all the
time
i would want a dog
do you prefer the beetles or the rolling
stones the stones i think i liked more
when i was
a kid growing up and if you're at a bar
right now i had a great jukebox and you
pick any rolling stones song to hear
like god i'd love to hear this one again
right now um
probably eleanor rigby
okay
all right we should i mean i don't know
much about that
well it doesn't sound like it um do you
um
and and and what would you put on a
burger what how would you top a
cheeseburger pretty simple uh ch cheddar
and maybe caramelized onions and ketchup
mustard oh oh that sounds simple that's
uh sounds delicious
or raw onion i like onion maybe i i
don't like tomato
as so much so i would do
uh
cheeseburger
raw onion or caramelized onions and
lettuce and ketchup mustard cool well uh
john i can't thank you enough this was
so funny oh cool man thanks no that was
really fun i'm always happy to tell the
diarrhea story well now i can and you
know it re-ups it because i hadn't told
it in
probably four years on the show so this
is good it will it really it's like a
regeneration of kids that can key into
my diarrhea it's
it's so good they should be remake they
should be diarrhea remaking that every
time
a diarrhea
i can't tell you how happy that made me
and um
thank you for sharing it and uh and it
must kind of make it worth
it happening you know like that you get
to have this great i feel that way about
really embarrassing or
you know any kind of like any nights any
experience that well it's kind of worth
it if you get to tell a really fun story
that's true so it's right it's a tragedy
that turns out right to be to make to
make people happy
well yeah so thanks for letting us laugh
at your um
situation i mean that's what i'm here
for yes
that's yeah it's people have been we've
come full circle i've been laughing at
my experience for 50 years i just could
keep
well it's really enjoyable and uh so
thanks for for
sitting there i and by the way you you
may you may have shot yourself now i
haven't seen below your waist
i have had to pee for about a half hour
so
okay great all right well i'm glad we're
ending um but but not because i haven't
enjoyed this that is so fun thanks john
all right thanks justin
[Music]
so that just happened that's pretty good
that's great that's pretty good your
impression of h on your so that happened
yeah that that happened yeah there's a
kind of a dignified you know what it is
that's what i thought
i think to george takai it's a little
george to guy he's kind of like that's
more george that's a good church
oh thank you well yes he's that's a fun
one to do i realized that
i i think i know why people say i sound
like him and i don't know if i sound
like him as much as i thought i sounded
like i don't think you do but but here's
what it is he's got a sort of i mean
he's got
we both have a nice tone
uh but here's the thing he has a certain
there's a certain
kind that i think i have too like a kind
of uh
like an attitude yes kind of an er like
aristocratic a little bit like a little
bit of like a kennedy
mixed with um yes with like a winklevoss
twin yeah
yeah you know and i think i have a
little bit of that too this sort of like
yeah it's a little kevin it's a little
like lockjaw talking about it's a
country club what we're going to do this
year at the country club in my opinions
i'm so con there's a confidence too this
kind of cavalier breezy yes and he's
very dry yeah he's hilarious hilarious
and very very dry to the point where
sometimes you don't know if he's choking
well i think i would suspect that people
might say that about me sometimes yeah i
bet that i'm really dry to the point
where people might not know what i'm
kidding
yeah i think so yeah i'm being serious
now no no i know yeah i know that but
it's good to tell the listeners i guess
um because there aren't any they can't
see your face either so i mean a lot of
that is picked up just from
from visual cues right that's true um
and you know me very well i know you
well but you also don't give away a lot
with your face with express i found
myself swinging he's making a face you
know who does it really well and i think
i may have gotten this a little bit from
him is zach galifianakis there's like a
little
he like lets the person know he's joking
in a really fun way
afterwards but but h and he did that too
h was called h
h was he was a really funny guy
h made me l
i love that he goes by h that's just
like a bit that is that friend i know
put it on uh like i know like wrote it
down he's like just like that yeah just
like how i have to
refer to myself yeah it's i i in that um
in those terms it's
because of that because he is like
doesn't have a tell really he's or he's
got like a very subtle tell when he's
joking it's really nice to get a laugh
from him
you know yes he does and he had a really
good laugh yeah he had like a
high-pitched laugh yeah he did he was
like
yeah he did
he like it almost like caught him off
guard yeah it was sort of like an
authentic version of stamos's laugh
i'm not saying that stamos doesn't have
an authentic by the way a friend of the
show very good friend of the show yeah
uh friend of ours i'm not saying he
occasionally slipped into like what
sounded like
a less authentic like right yeah yeah i
remember
it was kind of like that it was like
flirty
yeah but it was it was more like a
constellation sounding flirty like huh
okay like okay i'm gonna give it up oh
yeah i guess i think he might but he has
a different like stamos also has like a
real life
right
but h um this is not about j this is
about h yeah let's get back to h
um yes he is
he's so drunk he's like dry as a bone to
the point where he was when he was
talking about the birds he is d is a b i
thought um i really couldn't tell
if he
can't like really care about birds or
who's just like a bit i i've known a few
people like that in my life and i'm
always like fascinated by them like i
think martin star is a little bit like
this like there are people who are just
so they're so dry and i don't sometimes
i wonder if they're certain of how they
feel about something if they know their
point of view you know it's it's like in
this case i would say like
i wonder
i wonder if he must know but it's such a
mystery like that it's whether or not he
really loves persons i think this is he
does it's a mystery to me and to you but
i think he has a pretty clear point of
view i think he knows to the point where
there's like no [ __ ] with him uh-huh
you know there's he he doesn't try that
[ __ ] yeah he doesn't oh my god he
doesn't try to entertain no and no at
all he's just like very uh very natural
yeah i i aspire to be more like that but
i do think he cares about the birds
because then i went on his twitter and
so twitter is really funny that uh it's
videos of the bird watching bird
watching were all so dry and a little
difficult to tell if he was kidding or
not but
at a certain point i was like oh he
knows about birds like he knows the
names of different bird species so it
can't be just a bit yes he really does
he is he's a little bit like john
hodgman and i i think they're friends
yeah that makes sense that's the first
time i heard about it was through john
john would reference him and i i think
he kind of like admires his sense of
humor that does make sense right it does
it does yeah he uh
is truly he i like that he doesn't feel
the need to give it up um i wish
i've just been thinking about doing
these you mentioned we were doing all
these this press stuff and like i find
myself i used to be worse when i was
younger but i was much more eager to
please when i was younger but uh now i
mean we care about this movie lady the
man around september 7th out already uh
we care about it so much that like i
find myself being a little bit
eager in a way that h had none of like
he had none of that quality he was just
like
you know yeah whatever like if something
funny comes up it comes up well here's a
big difference
lady of the manor out now uh is our
first movie
and
as many movies as you've been in this is
the first movie you've directed and
wrote so
you are more eager whereas
h john
has
his two big shows right now are bob's
burgers and archer and they've both been
on for over a decade that's true so i
don't think he has the same
uh level of of you know enthusiastic
enthusiasm that he did when he was first
promoting it which we should get into
because when he was oh my god first uh
went to what was the upfronts is that
where he was headed yeah it was the tc
uh i forget what they're called anyway
it's like it's when they announced that
the new shows and like they
show like a little clip to all these
like ad buyers and stuff it's like the
big whatever tv thing so back then he
was
obviously and i think i was at i
honestly think i was there that's weird
i i had an animated show on fx and you
weren't in the lobby no no no not bad
but i remember um i saw like aisha tyler
there who's on the show i like i
remember seeing the contingent of she'd
be a good guest on the show yes i'm
gonna work on that um but sam rockwell's
ex-girlfriend i didn't know they dated
in high school isn't that funny really
yeah whoa yeah that's cool
um friend of the show a very good friend
of the show
but no like back he told that story and
i think part of it was
that there was an eagerness he was on a
first class flight this is all new to
him he was you know coming out to
promote this thing and he got
overzealous and and drank too much and
ate too much on the floor oh my god and
it led to this
horrible event but but that's how
different now he's like blase about it's
been 11 years it's such a great but he
was so enthused at that time that it led
to this horrible
[ __ ] story
i thought you're gonna say [ __ ] storm it
should i mean both it's a [ __ ] storm it
is those are the craziest stories i've
ever heard to the point where i thought
could this all be true does this could
this happen too specific i think it was
yeah i think i think it was but it's
like it seems cartoonish i know i mean
for someone who's in these hit animated
shows it genuinely sounded like a
cartoon especially for a guy like that
it was extra funny it would have been
funny for anyone but like especially for
a guy who's that kind of um
uh droll and
draw a guy who's he's like our friend uh
will yeah well carlo yeah shout out i
hope he's listening but yeah somebody
was that um
even keeled you know like he just seems
like such a even keeled person for them
to be panicky like that and to like do
things without thinking he just seems
like he thinks about everything and
everything is like there's a deliberate
nature to the way he speaks the way the
things he just seems um yeah really
control in control i hope people
accept that story is like i wonder how
people listeners of the show
i was thinking about this listening to
that story i was thinking
i wonder how listen to the show yeah how
they're gonna respond to this story
because
it is i mean my opinion is that it's
obviously
so disgusting and
and he painted such a picture that it
was very easy to picture and like very
entertaining painted
but like and and you have sympathy forum
it's it's funny it's also funny but it's
obviously it's so disgusting
um
but i wonder if people if it's like
funny enough entertaining enough to
overwhelm the disgusting elements of it
for people because it's really
truly repulsive yeah it is it's star i
mean it's tough it's like to me it was
to me it's much funnier than it is
repulsive which is why we kept it in the
showers of course but i know i in fact
and just the way he brought it up too he
was like
yeah when i first started from promoting
the show because he was talking about
how he didn't know the other cast he
caught me by surprise he had never he
had never met the other cast member so
he's like oh no it was the first time i
ever met them actually was when we were
promoting the show and that was the
that's when i diarrhea in my pants
and he said it so casually that you were
like wait diarrhead is such a funny verb
it's so funny
to use that
in a casual way it is diarrheaed
in my pants
i i do hope that valet or someone who
knows that ballet
writes in oh me
too i am dying to get their take on that
situation because you know i was
thinking about it because it he painted
like you said i hate to keep using or
painted a picture because i'm picturing
like
you know fingerprints
christian i knew somebody in our yeah
that we don't get into but they actually
did that as a kid used to i'm now my
stomach sorry sorry um but yeah that's
what i i imagined oh the details and
like
what that must have been like for
whoever whatever poor valet person
opened that door and must have sat in it
let's just sat in it sat down and that
because i've seen valet we've all seen
valleys like move cars they just like
they get in without them it's awful it's
awful and now i feel bad laughing at oh
i'm not laughing at the valet no i know
like the shame that john must feel from
like can you imagine doing that but
here's what i don't get here i was
laughing out loud by myself listening to
the story and
you know how hard it is for me to laugh
out loud by myself well it's true that
is rare but how about how rare is it
when we because we record these
interviews for the most part we record
them here in the house and like there's
we have a little room and i'll uh some
you know i'll leave i'll come out of the
room after an interview and be like
whatever i'll say like oh that went well
or whatever i'll say just something
generic about the thing usually but how
rare is it when i come out and i'm like
oh and i try to recount a story that
somebody yeah
i told my friend i've been telling
people that story
really yeah i told yeah i don't know if
it's your story to tell it's not i
attribute it to
no i know but i attribute the destroyed
h but i guess he'd be okay with it
because he did oh yeah publicly yeah
yeah it's it's too good to start if that
happened to me i would want everyone to
share it it's too good a story the
funniest part of that whole there's so
many different funny elements like
picturing him picturing like a montage
of him drinking on the plane and like
um it's also funny to picture
i started at a certain point picturing
bob from bob's burgers in this position
and like the whole thing was animated
and running through them but the
funniest part you should do you know
that cartoon radio that they animate
oh my god guys if you're listening
totally you should do that but the the
funniest part
from the show too it's kind of something
yeah it was him
sprinting into this fancy hotel and
and the security clocking him
and like chasing after him
when he like
the the uh panic that he had just about
i know the poop i i know and then like
add to that the panic of being chased by
cops is well i but you know it's funny
to picture that what's funny is that
his poo panic overrides his police panic
like that's how overwhelming that fear
it's true but but it's a funny blend oh
it's amazing yeah because also the cops
chasing him
if they knew who they were chasing
and like shorts i know but like
they were trying to
track down this guy this crazy guy in
their minds
but imagine like
knowingly running after someone who had
diarrhea all over the place do you think
it was so funny to think that they're
like trying to get to this person who's
like so disgusting what would you do if
you're a security guard and you saw a
guy i run in with like diarrhea
everywhere oh my god i mean i would you
i you know i hate to say this but
there's a i wonder if i would just
pretend to ignore it i wonder if i would
just be like you know that scene and
that scene in the town
where they're like they robbed
they robbed this bank like ben affleck
and is like gang jeremy renner and they
have like those masks and like those
like huge machine guns and stuff yeah
and they like all get out of their car
to like ditch one car to get into like
the getaway car and they like get out
with these huge guns and bags and stuff
and they just see that single boston cop
like a beat cop just sitting in his car
with like coffee
and he kind of like glances over and
there's this moment of tension where
they're like oh my god what's gonna
happen to this guy are they gonna shoot
him up and and the cop just kind of like
looks at them
takes it in and then looks away like it
looks the other way that's what i would
do if i were a scary guy
i was cornered by h diary at h john
h with all the d all over his b
made some incredible cameos i'm thinking
of semi-pro he's so funny in that but
this is oh this is like an award-winning
cameo entering this
is that of all the people
who could enter and have a cameo in this
in the lobby i know there's something
about jackie earl haley as is like it's
perfect oh it's perfect i know i mean
the tom brady stuff was really funny
imagine imagining him running
like bringing it to him yeah and uh but
jackie rightly is funny because you know
i guess he like did and the fact that he
was drunk and so wasn't like holding
anything back even the lady whoever was
at the counter was like putting
he did he did this as a visual i don't
know if he said it but he just put his
he said whoever's behind the counter put
their shirt over their nose
that's how bad it must it must have
horrific been her i mean it's rigged
jack i i want so badly to have jack here
haley on the show now i mean i did
before because i think he's like a
really great actor do you think there's
any way he doesn't remember this
maybe i mean
if he's really drunk yeah yeah um that's
the only way you think but that would be
the first question i mean it wouldn't
because it'd be impolite to ask him that
is the first question i know we
shouldn't have him on the show only
because that's all you're going to talk
to him about it's it's gonna be an hour
of talking about his experience in that
lobby no because what could he say i
mean he'd be like
i was in a hot lobby of a hotel and this
guy
approached the
the clerk with diarrhea all over himself
i mean what mark can you say and it's it
was like a great story like that is such
it's such a good thing to have in the
world it's because that that's the mark
of a truly great story one that makes
you enjoy the retelling of it it's so
good that you like
i mean i just had so much fun like
thinking about it and like retelling it
i when i think of h john benjamin now i
i know he's a great actor he's very
funny but i'm going to think of him as
like a famous like diarrheas
he is like a voice actor a diaries like
he's and he also was
somewhat reluctant to tell the whole
story because he's already told it yeah
so he was like i'll give you the short
version but then as he was giving all
these details i i realized you can't
really give the short version of that
that's not a story that story demands
a complete version
should we read a letter yeah
i know i know we've spent a lot of time
on it well the interview has spent a
long time on that so it's only right
okay
here's a letter sorry that whoever wrote
this has to follow that but also by the
way perhaps bears repeating that he
isn't just a diarrhea that he is like
you said a good a great actor and great
storyteller and it has an amazing voice
and is like i consider him like goals
for me well yeah like
having a recording studio in your house
and just recording
animated oh my god or doing voiceovers
that's if anyone's listening yeah and
you want like a knockoff shitty version
of h john benjamin
christian long
it's 2.72 yeah on instagram reach out uh
a c long benjamin uh that he's going
john benjamin he's got the perfect
career i think you do sound like him i
could be a knockoff version yeah i
really believe
well i need to be a little
self-deprecating that's true can be like
i can do what he does
about that guess that we have uh okay
this is from
n-n-e-e-n-e how would you say en what's
the last name lagunzad lagonzad
l-a-g-u-n-z-a-d
logan's logins that lagonzad n-a-n-a-e
i'm gonna say n-a yeah n-a i think
subject hello from the philippines
hey i think this might be our first
letter from the philippines that we've
read
dear justin and christian i am happy i
discovered your podcast late into the
game because i can choose which
interviews to listen to first
i haven't caught up yet because work
books chores lessons and netflix
interrupt my listening
okay annie that's a lot of things i get
work and i get chores
i get lessons but i get netflix too okay
add books all right never mind uh shame
on me and he says no shame on you even
though i just tried to she or she
oh
uh that i could not tell you oh i can
tell you because there is a photo
accompanying it i still don't know if i
can
say adorable photo adorable of a young n
a
um or maybe that's annie's age now but
it looks like an older photo if that's n
a now
she is
like the most advanced human being alive
and i just shamed her for doing chores
of a toddler she she looks about three
in this photo she is truly adorable one
of the cutest photos i've ever seen okay
uh back to annie but on days that i have
to go out i'm sure to have it on in the
car i enjoy the banter a lot and look
forward to your post game analysis well
hopefully you're enjoying this post game
uh i hope you like diarrhea stories
i'd like to know
i'd like to i'm sure anna did her share
of diary when she was that age i'm sure
yeah
maybe not in her pants at a hotel um i'd
like to know
would you rather be a zombie apocalypse
survivor
this is great would you rather be a
zombie apocalypse survivor living
day-to-day in stress and scarcity and
have to protect yourself and fellow
survivors from zombies including your
zombie turned friends and loved ones or
be an early victim without the stress
and scarcity but unknowingly kill and
eat your family and loved ones huh
that is a great question
so the second option you're a zombie
the second option you're a yes you're a
zombie okay so you but you survive as a
zombie
yeah but it's a stress phrase
i was doing that being a zombie stress
freak which it must be zombies seem like
that zombie that's what i was going to
say zombies never seem
it doesn't seem like a bad existence not
a zombie it doesn't you just like want
stuff and you're like sometimes i feel
like is that at my you know when you're
like really you want whatever yeah you
just want it's like
zombies feel like uh humans at their
most base
like animal yeah and existences you know
they just want like food which i've
enjoyed
i've enjoyed both those words do zombies
want sex maybe not i don't think they
want sex but they want bro i think
certain brains they replace brains with
sex uh-huh i mean
yeah brains with sex they want brains
the same way that we not the same way
they replace sex with brains right
yes you're right homeboy speaking of not
having speaking of needing a brain um i
would i would almost certainly pick the
second option because the the first
option
you're constantly scared and you have to
see your family and your friends as
zombies well here's the thing and you
have to be afraid of them and the second
one is that would be horrible the second
one it's horrible that you unwillingly
killed
your
friends you don't know that and and then
they're just zombies right and they're
gonna be zombies anyway at some point
how long can everyone survive in the
zombie apocalypse but then think about
this let me add a little uh caveat um
she says it's yes i imagine it'd be
stressful and there's there's a scarcity
there's an element of like survival that
must be very stress
but don't you think within that i
haven't really seen the walking dead but
um i'm sure there are moments
uh because that's the documentary about
the zombie apocalypse i'm sure there are
moments where you still get to enjoy the
pleasures of the world and like
time with loved ones and the ones that
are living that are surviving you you
mean for if you're still alive yeah if
you're still alive it doesn't sound like
you sound like it sounds like you're on
your own exactly well in that case yeah
i think i
want to be a zombie i mean i know that
makes me sound like a follower and just
like it just seems so much easier you're
right i think i'm naturally i mean the
question ultimately is are you more of a
leader or a follower and i think i'm
more of a follower so that's why i lean
towards the second but what about the
hope of maybe finding
a loved one a friend out there love
again i don't know if i'm optimistic
enough i know what you're saying i agree
with you i wish i was more i know i
think the thing is i wish i wanted to
pick a more yeah but i naturally lean
towards b
b
zombie
z
that's a good question this is a great
question finally please find backpack to
annie finally please find my preschool
graduation picture for your amusement
cute preschool so that's what four
that is for for school hey that's the
last time i [ __ ] my pants oh my god full
circle yeah weird full full circle yeah
um back to any she says in each of these
words is its own capital sentence
that smile is hard to pin down
then
princess justin you know hashtag early
to
the awkward game early to the awkward
game okay i don't think she's awful i
don't either that's not in that picture
the smile is a little i mean i get i
mean every little kid picture is a
little awkward um i remember being so
awkward in those school photos i i have
one that i just saw the other day i was
showing my friend it was like my hands
were weirdly positioned on blocks
remember when they would do that they
would have like props for kids to
it it's supposed to affect the looked
look of like natural like being like
casual it's a weird thing to show a
friend though
i guess you must feel very comfortable
i do yeah i do yeah very comfortable
okay um thanks
okay back to any thank you for reading
my email and i hope you can feature some
more comedians on your podcast oh good
we have yeah well h john benjamin yeah
so that's right how could i just think
of him as a diarrhea
uh how can we view your movie in the
philippines oh great from any good
question i don't know that's a good
question
well don't
don't they have like apple tv and stuff
that's the question we should have an
answer to we should as filmmakers and as
people who have been like shamelessly
promoting
their movie mm-hmm um well let's look at
what we're going to look into that and
i'm going to post about it on the gram
it's available
now yeah as i said before on dvd and
blu-ray i imagine you can get those
things
in the philippines yeah it's it was in a
few theaters here in the states i don't
i don't think whatever i'm sure you can
get it on on demand there but regardless
thank you for your you can demand things
in the philippines i would think so but
thank you for your interest that's
really kind that is very kind and great
would you rather um an adorable photo
that letter had a little bit of a real
winner letter yeah thank you na um
and thank you to all of you and to our
esteemed guest h john benjamin yes thank
you to h and to all that gold gold's me
gosh yeah that's right not the diarrhea
part but everything else c
c long bench yeah well the diary part
would be
if that were to happen to you i'm sure
you would tell it in as equally and
entertaining way perhaps yeah i mean
fingers crossed
fingers crossed i don't have to cross
that bridge that's right fingers crossed
and butthole clenched
um and so thanks to h and to all the s's
for l elling listening yeah all the
shorties shorties for listening and uh
and we'll we'll talk to you next w ah
good wrap up t
could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is aged by me justin long
it is ch by you christian long you also
see produce it along with megan v monaco
and uh interim producer katie allen and
senior producer is michelle miesh lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producer is marshall louie for
a company called wandery
[Music]
like if i if i was in the big brother
program uh-huh
and he was and he was like
one of the boys in it uh-huh they
definitely would pair us together you'd
you'd like him too much you'd it'd be
whatever
you'd be like
intimidated by him i think and you try
too hard uh
he's still a little kid he's still like
13. yeah but he's a jeopardy champion
not yet he's not he's really smart he's
smarter than you
he knows more stuff than me and he
probably has a better brain than me
wouldn't you be making kind of [ __ ] but
but i've made no because i've
experienced things that he he'll never
get to experience do you think people
would find it weird if you because you'd
want to bring him place you'd want to
hang out with him socially i bet
you think he's that much smarter than me
no but i think you'd like him so much
yeah i but i can hang out with people
smarter than me and and not get too
insecure i'm not a 14 year old well i'd
be like he's like worms are he's he's
special he's not like a normal girl
though
he does
this he does maybe i would be
intimidated
he's got that devil my character yeah
yeah oh it's all about
it's like kind of it's like he just woke
up and he never thought he didn't care
yeah like he knows people will like him
even if he has weird hair
yeah he seems like he's kind of a humble
oh like a yeah like a little michael
sarah yeah like a free thinker
yeah i like him
maybe i couldn't mentor him maybe he
needs to mentor me
i mean it's also very flattering for you
that you would be able to mentor him
he's so like smart and cool he's still a
kid
i just mean in terms of like what would
you teach him about uh
what do big brothers and sisters do i
don't think it's about teaching it's
about
being there for advice like if he says
this kid oh like social stuff yeah i
think so it'd be really nice i i would
love to i'm not good i'm not gonna help
him with his math homework no i know i
i'd love to like teach him about the
world or try to
yeah and how to talk to a girl because
there's so much he has so much promise
you know yeah because i'm sure one day
he will be better than me at talking to
girls but right now he's probably not
probably not but maybe what he could be
like a little savant like a little
social
not social savant i don't know
he's too smart he's been on his own too
much he's
he you know he'll and girls that age
it's it's they won't recognize his charm
i don't think
really i don't think so he'd be like
what's a pleasure he'd be polite maybe
you're right and you try to make a joke
and like you do a girl
and they just think you're being weird
you